les riches des grandes villes vivent
dans de luxueux appartements
mais l'heure est tellement paul et
qu'ils arrivent même pas à voir les
étoiles
il faudrait être fou pour vouloir
échanger notre place avec la leur le
docteur taylor a dit conte devra aller
dans une vraie école une vraie école ya
pas plus vrai que ça les enfants avec
nous c'est l'école de la vie qui
seraient devrait pas avoir honte de nous
parce qu'on n'a pas choisi le même style
de vie que toi et que oui depuis quand
tu as perdu ton goût pour l'aventuré
aller au combat
les enfants en ont marre de changer de
ville à chaque fois que tu perds ton
boulot il faut qu'on trouve l'endroit
parfait où se loger et on pourra
construire notre chien
[Musique]
cet endroit n'a ni eau courante ni
électricité in your love elle n'a pas
d'imagination
mais pas comme les autres on a comme une
sorte de feu qui nous brûle les
entrailles tu es né pour changer le
monde va pour renforcer le bruit ambiant
pourquoi tu crois qu'on s'est tous
éloignés toi
on était en train de sombrer
est prête
à
[Musique]
tuez pas comme moi aussi je suis comme
toi et ça me plaît